can you pass me the milk the milk yeah  the milk m IL ok yes I said no you said  Mel no milk no milk and we're saying the  same thing  we're not thank you for the milk I'm  gonna really enjoy my milk  pecan pecan mayonnaise mayonnaise tomato  that's a tomato for tomorrow  well then how do you say potato good  data well if you say potato then you  should say tomato potato tomato I'll  enjoy this tomato jewelry Oh jewelry no  he said it jewelry no some jewelry good  again  jewelry no what jewelry I'm done I'm  just gonna sit here and click my coupons  you mean coupon my coupons koopa koopas  your mama's what you're speaking over  him  what are you guys fighting about  let's see what Google has let's say  there's a coupon for your bad attitude  how about that coupon coupon